la dedicación de estos estudiantes que
aprenden chino Es evidente a medida que
Moscú y Beijing refuerzan su Alianza
diplomática cada vez más rusos estudian
mandarín en esta escuela de idiomas
creada por una pareja ruso china el
número de solicitudes se ha duplicado
este año los dos empresarios esperan que
la visita de Shin Pink ayude a mantener
este impulso nuevo
creemos que las clases de chino en el
mercado ruso son ahora una tendencia muy
prometedora mi opinión personal es que
las relaciones entre Rusia y China serán
aún mejores Somos buenos colegas y
vecinos en la agenda de la visita de
tres días la guerra en Ucrania
nunca ha condenado la invasión Pero el
mes pasado propuso un plan de paz para
poner fin a los combates otro tema
central de la visita la creciente
cooperación económica entre ambos países
bajo las sanciones occidentales la
economía rusa se apoya cada vez más en
la de su vecino con compra de petróleo y
gas ruso por parte de China y la venta
de productos electrónicos y vehículos a
Rusia las transacciones bilaterales
alcanzaron la cifras récord de 190.000
millones de dólares en 2022 a pesar de
estos lazos las empresas chinas
difícilmente pueden permitirse dar la
espalda a los mercados europeos y
estadounidenses
está China dispuesta a sacrificar su
capacidad para comerciar con occidente
para construir su papel como le gusta
hablar de sí mismo como un actor
internacional responsable está dispuesta
a sacrificar eso en interés de Moscú
más cerca de Moscú que de kiev China se
enfrenta un acto de equilibrio en el
conflicto Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea han acusado al país de pretender
suministrar armas a Rusia lo que Beijing
ha negado